that commission and the left is also
using january 6 as a pretext
of course to completely remake our
military and
target conservatives in the ranks
the job of the department of defense is
to keep america safe from our enemies
but we can't do that if some of those
enemies lie within our own ranks
we're also tackling the problem of
violent extremists
in our work in our ranks in our
workforce we establish the countering
extremism working group what about the
extremists that are
running the pentagon joining me now is
arkansas senator tom cotton of the armed
services committee
senator senator the pentagon very clear
on
who their whom they're trying to purge
so why should republicans
rubber stamp funding for a military that
is being turned into this
wokefied factory branding conservatives
as extremists
laura we're not going to in the weeks
ahead as we start to write the annual
defense bill i'm going to be taking up
this matter i've already introduced
legislation
that would forbid the military from
teaching critical race theory at our
service academies or professional
military schools
and there's nothing that could be more
divisive more destructive of morale and
a
common fighting ethos among our troops
in critical race theory than saying some
races
are inherently privileged or some races
are inherently oppressed or
victimized that's the exact opposite of
what we should be teaching
our young troopers which what we want to
teach them
is to love their country to defend their
country and look at the man or the woman
on the right or left as a fellow but
senator i'm sorry to interrupt
your representative right but you won't
get that past that's
that's a that's a great piece of
legislation but with biden as president
and
nancy in charge in the house that's not
going anywhere but you can prevent
the funding of this with the republican
votes because
plenty of democrats don't want to give
any increase in spending to the military
so if you guys hold up the funding
they're suddenly going to listen will
you do that
yeah that may be a step we have to take
laura but i wouldn't say that we can't
get that passed either remember the
defense bill passes every year it has
passed every year for 60 years
we have an open amendment process in the
committee and on the floor
i think there may be one or two
democrats who don't think that we should
be teaching our troops
that the most important thing about them
is the color of their skin rather than
their ability to help save the lives of
the man and woman
to their right and to their left this we
get all kinds
of calls and letters and emails coming
to my office i would encourage
all troopers tonight if they're being
indoctrinated with this kind of nonsense
to contact us cotton.senate.gov
we welcome whistleblowers you can send
us your experiences you can send us the
documents that are you that are being
seen
we want to stand up for you we want to
make sure that you're spending your time
training to fight and to win our
country's wars and to take care of your
battle buddies
i mean the secretary of defense he's
calling
the troops the enemies i i've never
thought i would be in a country
where the secretary of defense would
call our troops some of them
the enemies i i i i i hope
everybody listened to that clip if you
had missed it when we played it before
but
i got to ask you similarly this new
report from the intercept
is revealing senator that the pentagon
is launching a pilot program to monitor
the social media accounts of our
military personnel for extremism
so john kirby denied it but then he
added this
there's no effort inside this extremist
working group
to somehow spy on every individual in
the military or
spend hours and hours just gleaning
through social media
activity just for the sake of doing it
what we are interested in doing is
seeing how the services are doing it as
they recruit see if there's things that
can be learned things that can be
improved
do you buy that they're not trying to
target uh traditionalists or
conservatives
yeah we're going to get to the bottom of
that because it was a very disturbing
report
john kirby has denied it look the
military's always
screened for extremists i remember when
i enlisted years ago you had to
write down what tattoos you had and
describe them provide pictures of them
make sure there weren't any
people with gang tattoos being listed in
the military but if the military was
proposing to
actively monitor social media accounts
of our troopers on an
ongoing basis to look for partisan or
political statements
that would be an extreme overreach which
wouldn't be surprised because this
so-called extremist working group
is filled with extremists itself so
we're going to be getting answers to
these questions soon
who knows better about the finding an
extremist senator
than the extremists i guess that takes
one to no one senator good to see you
tonight thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else